what it do everybody my name is ross
panetta chef and owner of fly kitchen
and today we're going to be testing five
famous celebrity hot dog recipes on
today's lineup we have chrissy teigen
david chang
tabitha brown maddie matheson and gordon
ramsay so i measured out all the
ingredients exactly as each recipe
stated and i brought three of my friends
here to see which one is their favorite
so i got a question for you guys
is the hot dog a sandwich i don't know
but let's get these glizzies cracking
so first up we have chrissy teigen she
starts off by boiling some macaroni for
her macaroni salad we're gonna cut up
some scallions
jalapenos red onion toss it in a bowl
with salt and pepper we're gonna top
that off with ketchup
mustard mayo and relish to finish off
the topping for her macaroni salad
once the macaroni salad is finished
she's gonna butter the top and bottom of
her buns and toast it in a pan and fry
up her hot dog
once the hot dog is finished cooking
she's going to top it off with some
ketchup
mustard relish macaroni salad and
crushed the barbecue chips and there you
have it chrissy teigen's loaded mac dog
so this one looks interesting
there's chips macaroni i don't know what
kind of sauce is on here
let's get it going
the macaroni and the chips taste really
good with the hot dog this one's
actually really good
it kind of gives like a cold salad kind
of vibe something you would find at a
barbecue you just throw everything on
your plate
because you don't want to go back for
seconds this probably isn't something i
would order like off the menu that if i
would see what ingredients were on it
but after tasting it it's actually
really good
next up we have david chang's chang dog
recipe first he's going to start off by
wrapping up a hot dog and a slice of
bacon
once you have all five wrapped up you're
gonna cut up some kimchi and set that
aside for the topping
in a hot pan you're gonna cook the bacon
wrapped hot dogs slowly on each side
so all the sides of the bacon get nice
and crispy
once the hot dog is done cooking you're
gonna set it up in a bun and top it off
with the kimchi
and boom there you have it david chang's
chain dog
this one looks like it has kimchi on it
let's try it
this one is spicy really spicy once you
get past the spicy the onions and the
hot dogs do taste good but
it's hot i got some bacon wrapped around
the hot dog which is pretty good for
that spice though
not for me i feel like this would be for
somebody who really likes korean food
who really wants to put kimchi on
everything but this is one that's
definitely enough for me
next up we have everyone's favorite
vegan specialist tabitha brown
she starts off by peeling some carrots
make sure you peel it over a towel to
eliminate the mess
she's gonna top and tail the carrots and
set them aside so we can get our liquid
together so in a large pot she brings
together water
amino acids liquid smoke a1 steak sauce
agave and ketchup you're gonna drop in
your carrots
and cook for about 10 minutes or so
until tender once the carrots are done
cooking she tops it off
with ketchup mustard and relish
this one here looks very interesting
doesn't look like an ordinary hot dog
all right i'm gonna give it a shot
though if you're vegan
this is for you so this is a carrot in
the buns
something bugs bunny would order the
carrot is very soft it just has like
that
garden taste to it i don't think it goes
really well with the mustard like i
would
rather put like barbecue sauce on it
just to get more of like a meat vibe
from it i wouldn't put the regular
condiments that they put on a hot dog
next up we got maddie madison's
different approach to a hot dog recipe
he starts off by frying up some fries
in hot oil about 350 degrees once the
fries are done he's going to set him
aside and we're going to start building
our roux
in a pan he's going to add flour and
butter once the flour and butter
start getting a golden brown color we're
going to slowly add some chicken stock
until it gets the sauce consistency
at this point we're going to season it
with salt pepper
poultry seasoning white pepper ketchup
and soy sauce
once the gravy has come to a simmer he's
going to cut up some hot dogs and warm
those through in the sauce
lastly he throws in some frozen peas now
we're going to assemble the dish
we're going to layer some french fries
and cheese curd and top it off with the
hot gravy so that the cheese skirts
melt if you don't know now you know hot
dog poutine
this one looks like something i really
enjoy this looks delicious
french fries cut up hot dogs looking
like a poutine
this one i like this tastes really good
this is something i would definitely
order this was like
if i ordered it from like a diner all
the components are there sweet savory
spicy this is definitely like for a
child it's everything on one plate this
one's really good i like this
it's all right it's decent and now the
moment you've all been waiting for
gordon ramsay's hot dog recipe he's
gonna start off by cutting up some
onions
and sauteing it in a pan with garlic
once that's all nicely cooked out he's
gonna throw in some cumin seed and chili
pepper once that's all nicely toasted
he's gonna throw in some ground beef and
we're gonna cook that out
we're gonna season it with some
worcestershire sauce don't add me we're
gonna add some tomato paste we're gonna
cook it out so that you get rid of the
iron taste
he's gonna season it with salt pepper
dried oregano
sugar and lastly throw in some crushed
tomatoes
we're gonna cook it out slowly once
that's all done cooking bung in a bun
and top that off with the chili and
there it is folks gordon ramsay's chili
dog this one looks like a taco hot dog
like sloppy joe kind of thing
this one right here is heavy this one's
okay but it reminds me of
public school lunch flavors are there
seasoned very well
something i would order something to
find out a carnival or maybe at a
ballpark
it's really just average there's nothing
special about this if i was given this
i would eat it but would i buy it no so
which liberty has the best hot dog
recipe
let's find out out of these five
celebrity hot dog recipes i would choose
the
hot dog with the macaroni and the chips
on it i got more of like a
summer vibe from it and it seemed like a
typical hot dog that i would actually
want to buy
so we made it all chrissy teasing that's
my girl
out of these five celebrity hot dogs my
favorite one definitely has to be
the poutine one the french fries with
the mozzarella cheese and the cut up hot
dogs that's something that
i would go for immediately if i was at a
restaurant who made the poutine one
chef i need to find out who that is out
of these
five i would choose the first one
because the mac and cheese was just
on point who made this hot dog oh
chrissy teigen
i love her so there you have it christy
teigen takes today's celebrity glizzy
challenge
which celebrity recipe should we try
next leave a comment below
you